[Musique]
initierez alors c'est cédric humaine y
regarde tu peux tout ce qui se passe
dans les missions d'audit a fait quoi je
survive en fait ya une chose qui vous
traumatise j'ai remarqué c'est faire des
duplex
ah ouais ça vous trouvent a dit ça vous
fait encore plus peur que de regarder
l'émission de michel cymes et j'ai
remarqué et se dire le niveau quand même
alors pourtant hier soir vous allez
tenter le plus gros challenge votre
carrière un duplex avec une ville située
à 8900 4 km de boulogne à maurane
c'est ce que je remarque c'est fou quand
même est ce que j'ai remarqué ce qui est
ce que plus le duplex est loin plus
fonctionne plus le duplex est proche du
plateau plus une catastrophe mais c'est
ça on n'y peut on n'est pas prêt c'est
vrai mais vous êtes un petit peu
l'aventurier du duplex perdu
[Musique]
hier vous tente un duplex avec burhan en
chine et chose incroyable pas un bug pas
une coupure de son on dirait que les
interlocuteurs sont à sucy en brie
on a deux personnes en direct de vue ren
en chinois en ce cas et ouais les mecs
quoi et qualaa les voilà ben bonjour
jeunes acteurs et rémy désolé de vous
déranger en pleine nuit un bon jour
alors que souvenez vous de votre duplex
légendaire avec jérôme commandeur et
laurent weil depuis los angeles à
montrer dans toutes les écoles de du
fleix il vantant way temps à autre en
tentant connard oui autant vous avez des
questions ou c'est juste pour me faire
perdre mon temps soeur m'a dit que tu as
un truc à dire moi oui
ah non non moi aussi on m'a dit que
c'était toi qui avait un truc à me dis
je
on se fait chier à faire un duplex à los
angeles avec trois personnes qui n'ont
rien à se dire et à noël vous avez tenté
un duplex avec moctar à marseille
c'était un franc succès aussi de plus en
plus proche
mokhtar est ce que tu m'entends mon
chéri
c'est le cadreur est mort nessma tard
s'il vous plaît beaucoup car voilà donc
apparemment ils sont en train de voilà
ils sont ils sont petits sont pas prêtes
merci merci en tout cas ce qu est un
très beau duplex et même pour en duplex
depuis un endroit qui se trouve à deux
kilomètres du studio c'est la
catastrophe
bonsoir cyril bon soir tu vas bien et du
rythme
il m'a dit m'a dit salma qui reviendra
travailler avec l'ouverture sa salle
basse travaille à la rédaction de touche
pas à mon poste qu'on embrasse sache
exactement la rédaction alors mathieu
vous êtes un grand animateur jeudi grand
pour la taille parce que pour le talent
on va attendre encore quelques années
mais votre objectif numéro un c'est
moche non dans ce que je vais faire
vous êtes très content parce que votre
objectif numéro un c'est quoi c'est le
pont guerre cyril hanouna bien sûr son
coeur on pensait que la barre est
possible sa place ça serait quoi on
pensait que rien ne serait possible
entre vous mais j'ai des images qui vont
tout changer vous allez voir maman de
voir ces images qui vont bouleverser
votre vie mathieu un petit rappel de la
relation entre vous qu'un peu le je
t'aime moi non plus en fait celle là là
un petit peu mais on a un chat à les
séparer
alors mathieu est un amoureux de lui
même des chiens avec vous mais surtout
il est amoureux de vous cyril et quand
il voudra que ça se voit pas du tout
qu'est ce que tu aimerais avoir comme
cadeau un week-end akbar allah - année
où c'est dans son cul je pense que dans
un lit vous êtes une queen revanche on
m'a toujours dit non je n'ai pas de
dépôt des vêtements mouillés sait le
faire ça pour attraper la crève
mais on est lié c'est des trucs deux
mois je crois beaucoup à ça en ce moment
je fais de l'acupuncture de l'ésotérisme
de ça les boîtes nous ramène résistons
nous ramène le captal grille et nous
ramène vous voulez quoi moi ouais toi
[Musique]
phénomène vous connaissez vous
connaissez un peu
ouais vous l'aimez bien ouais avez vous
fait rire ouais ça va bah tu vois alors
là hein mais qu'est ce que tout le monde
même aujourd'hui abattant un thème c'est
normal ça que nous deux c'est bizarre
parce alors justement pas vous engueuler
au téléphone ils ont à m'acheter mes
carême pu était à sa taille
alors donc quand on vient de voir votre
relation mais on a constaté que mathieu
c'était l'amoureux transi devant vous
que cyril mais vous êtes hermétique à
son chant pourtant il a un physique
situé entre stallone et cyril féraud et
j'ai des images qui prouvent qu'elle
ferait beau tous les domaines et un
chausson très différent quand je sais
pas alors j'ai des images qui prouvent
que cyril vous commencé à tomber sous le
charme de matthieu delormeau ne reproche
pas dessus écoutez je regardais la
semaine dernière j'ai des données parce
que vous avez déclaré qu en détaillant
le programme de la semaine
vous avez été très précis entré chez
vous vous aurez des enquêtes rivés sur
vous dire le lundi je regarde créer une
crime le mardi je regarde ton cul le
marché le dimanche je regarde encore ton
qu est ce que les prix pour une vanne
était vrai siri vous avez à vous et
regardez le cul plus de matthieu
delormeau le mardi et le dimanche mais
c'est faux vous aimez tellement regardé
le cul cul de matthieu delormeau que
dans fait même discrètement pendant
l'émission
bien entendu j'ai tout vu mathieu ces
cadeaux c'est pour vous
cc regarder ces cadeaux haut
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ha ignoble d'en sortir
tu cherchais pas la marque de jeans
escompté en garde elle mais je regarde
la table pour savoir comment j'allais
mais ce n'est pas du tout je vous jure
que c'est vrai après tout quoi non mais
attendez
il regarde donc une table ça se regarde
pas comme ça tu dois je suis témoin vote
après mon retour vous savez que votre
regard des très rares pas du tout pas
des merveilles par irene ce qu'on dit et
corporelle la bouée battre et on va
s'aimer très temporelles ocha au tchad a
franchement vous mais ne vous méprenez
pas je vous le dis vous voyez ce que
vous parlez aux bébés yémen tu vois déjà
garés à table voilà merci
cédric one tarifs bénéfique et pas
d'érection que c'est un cadeau pour vous
merci zeddam alors jean-michel c'est le
beau gosse de la bande celui à aucune
fois que acquis aucune femme ne réserve
aux yeux rouges aucune femme qui vous va
si jean-michel un hôtel portman à
geneviève de fontenay
tout le monde tombe dans vos bras les
sacs dans la vie à michel il séduit
toutes les meufs
ouais mais en plateau j'ai remarqué
qu'en fait ils se transforment en maxime
gainey c'est vrai dick est une petite
nouvelle dans l'équipe comme sophie
cause par exemple il tente sa chance
le problème c'est qu'à force de se faire
recaler par les nouvelles il va finir
par être surnommé râteau man
souvenez vous que la semaine dernière
sophie koch a émis un râteau en douceur
un jean michel maire j'aime les choses
suit à peu de le dire comme comme sophie
on est comme oui sophy fait déjà très
complices voilà ce que moi je passe
quelque chose je sens que je pense que
j'ai à blanche mois qu'il se passe
quelque chose que toi de ton côté
[Musique]
dans les chaînes a toujours eu décroche
pour les nouvelles gemmes pour kelly je
m'en rappeler même pas si ce fait les
pieds au c ur répond tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean-michel des cas une petite nouvelle
ils font mon amour surtout quand la
nouvelle c'est une ex miss france
delphine wespiser petit croche ah bah
pas un petit et il est même tombé
amoureux de l'intellectuel de la bande
géraldine maillet maxime l'amour de ma
vie j'aurais dit géraldine qui devrait
prouver qu'elle était très réceptive à
l'amour de jean michel j'en oublie moi
à commencer
[Musique]
en fait la seule fois qu'une nouvelle
voulait enfin pécho jean-michel
bizarrement n'étaient pas chaudes du
toulouse daniel vous avez quelqu'un vous
avez choisi qui font le sel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est faute et passe à satee place après
les magnifiques daniel que j'embrasse
qui est magnifique et très belle famille
je pouvais pas lescar que d'embrasser
aussi bas aussi je l'adoré daniel c'est
un mauvais timing puisque c'était en
coupe à ce moment là par exemple à turin
c'est pas la tête à ça les panams
également fidèle il est fidèle
ici à 6,6 à 6 ha bah là tu te trompes
tour et d'agneaux si elle est fidèle
wima à oui c'est moi la fin et daniel
elle est là mais là vous êtes seul en
son honneur
las sa bouche on n'avait pas peur de
quelque chose qui se passe les
transferts très bientôt on sera tous
demain je vous le dis il pmp le jeu vous
verrez je sais exactement ce qui se
passe ouhlala bah oui alors la lch take
two qui je vais te balades demain non
vous allez être malades après alors
chaque mercredi pour finir je vous
montre la révolte des chroniqueurs quand
il permet de vous venez syrie la wii
parce qu'ils se vengent de vos tags
parce que là on saura demain si vous
êtes le 27e temps là-bas consécutive pas
en attendant c'est le ba-ba clash on
commence quand les chroniqueurs ne vous
crois pas qu'on vous le racontez vous
grattez vous même la neige sur le pare
brise de votre twingo
[Musique]
mon corps qui naissent perdent et tan
tan as et que tu sors de chez toi frère
était comme ça avec les chaussures de la
voiture enlevé avec mme ashton a jamais
de retraite
qu'est ce que tu possèdes et pro tu
prends un slip ou un cd vous êtes le
chauffeur s'est alors je vous montrais
des maisons à votre avis c'est la maison
de qui ont regardé des maisons folle
regardez là j'en ai une la regarder ces
régionales et et à gaza
je mets une des balles j'offre mon
salaire du jour à téléspectateurs 5 les
changes et demi la sérénade à toi qui
peux arrêter de bosser jusqu'à celle en
forêt en forêt forêt de rambouillet ça
compte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors il s'est mis au tennis a gelé vue
ouïe spectaculaire benjamin je devais
jouer au tennis est spectaculaire et je
pense que c'est en traîne encore une
semaine et vous met une taule je pense
que dans 15 ou 20 jours
je vous mets au défi et vous allez
souffrir
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont pas top paris
institution a d'ailleurs c'était il ya
dix jours vous êtes mois la fumée
passive ou les bouchoux vendredi je
serai prêt vendredi l'émission affaires
non mais vendre votre ton émission ça va
tu la feras avant a été mise avant tu
verrais courte maintenant ça me gêne à
ronny keller à quelle heure je jouais à
quelle heure alors que tu veux à quelle
heure alors j'ai réunion à 11 heures on
va dire 10 heures à 10 heures tu joues
avec moi dans 9h30 9h30 9h à 20h
vendredi moi je me couche tard le jeudi
on ne mérite quoi t'as jamais les yeux
ouverts mais c'est pas là ça ne vole pas
un bleu marine milan nord 14 heures
mélangeant les derniers mission paddle
japa dog vendredi à midi je peux pas je
rentre pas et bâle aurait la nuit ou
dimanche vous défiler samedi et comme ça
a dit samedi salle les si vous voulez
samedi quand tu me tues tu choisis ton
dès le 20 du mois de l'année tu rentres
chez toi
[Applaudissements]